Hello. My name is Mike loads.
And today I'm going to be taking a look at how medieval weapons and
armor are portrayed in video games.
[Inaudible].
Video games. I'm going to take a look at today. Uh,
kingdom come the Witcher for honor,
model chivalry, dark souls on mountain blade.
Let's take a look at how swords are used in video games,
forging a sword kingdom, come deliverance.
Do it.
So what we see in this clip is the finishing stages the blade has already
been made.
But what I like about this clip is these people clearly are taking
care. You know what you're doing? High status swords. They were made by alchemy.
It's an incredibly sophisticated process.
Give it here. We'll put it all together.
Where it goes slightly wrong is where he's putting the grip on at the end.
Lou, it's true that you would heat the time.
That's the little bit that comes up from the blade for, for the grip to go on.
What they're doing there is they've heated. Half the blade, all that art,
all that care to get the proper spring temper will have been lost
because they've heated it up in front of the way
I may have a little technical problem is when they put the pommel on that's the
bit that balances a sword at the end, when they put that on,
they just plop it on. Well, the,
the time that should come through the pommel.
So there's a little bit sticking up and then you hammer that over and
split it out, peanut out, revert it out.
And that's what holds everything secure. And together,
this Palmer would have fallen off as soon as they picked it up.
So little details are wrong, but the feel of the thing is great.
It's magnificent 100 versus two handed use of the
sword dark. So.
If you tap, why, when you're in a situation like this,
when you have a one handed sword and a shield, you switched to two handed,
but blocking with a sword doesn't really work.
They kind of completely misunderstand how swords are used.
Doesn't block a hundred percent of the damage that's just wrong.
Putting two hands hands-on will give you a more powerful stroke.
It does not in any way, hinder your ability to defend with a sword
when you're using a single handed, an arming sword with one hand,
and then clearly you're always going to favor your dominant arm because mostly
that's going to be the stronger arm pens. I know,
but the mighty that the sore you don't ever block with a
sword, that's not how it's done. I'm using a front. I knock it aside.
I'm keeping a flow. So this idea of square blocking,
it may be easier for game developers to create that kind of action,
but it's not how it was done.
Single edged swords versus double-edged swords.
You know, the first thing I've got to say about that clip is how good I
thought the action was. I mean, the armor, what was distracting?
Cause it's so fantastically.
Wrong.
The body shapes the movements, the positions they got in,
that was good. It had quality there.
Good.
The advantage of a two-inch sword is if one edge is getting a little dulled,
you can turn it around and you've got a second edge to you.
So it can be a considerable advantage on the battlefield that you're keeping one
edge sharp.
The advantage of a single edge sword is usually that it's less
expensive because you don't have to have such a sophisticated
temper.
That.
Is authentic. As long as you're gripping tight enough,
the sword won't move. And if it doesn't move, it won't cut you.
So.
This person is not able to pull it through this person's hand because this
person has taken it and they turned it into a lever action,
removing the sword from their hand.
So those kinds of blade grabbing this arms are authentic
and they are possible,
but they require skill and knowledge and do not try this at home.
Throwing a sword.
Soldiers are extremely versatile weapons. That's one of their advantages.
You can use them in all sorts of different ways.
A powerful man with a powerful thrust,
delivering a thrust to somebody's chest could almost stop a heart.
You can use it as a lever to unbalance your opponent.
You've got that great heavy pommel, that great metal weight on the end,
and you can deflect the sword and use the pommel to smash and punch.
Why, why would you throw it?
It is so stupid to throw away a
weapon and there's not even the person that's locked in by the weapons.
I just can't get my head around the idea of somebody throwing a sword,
decapitation, chivalry.
[Inaudible].
So what we see here is clearly supposed to be a European medieval
battlefield. And so in that context,
you wouldn't see heads cut off in this way.
Not least of all, because they're wearing.
[Inaudible].
Could a saw do it. Yeah, you could do it.
If you were fighting an army of naked people, you know,
the neck is one of the first areas to get protective equipment.
Even if you've got nothing else, you'd have a male color or coy of something.
Wow.
Of the ways in which Arbor defends you is by creating curves
surfaces, glancing surfaces. And of course the body is always moving as well.
So you can never land a pure 90 degrees strikes.
You need enough edge just to bite in order to send that energy through.
And I don't believe heads fly like that. Decorated swords for honor.
Your hungers for blood.
Obviously the first thing to say about decoration,
it was only ever available to the wealthy, uh,
to princes and Kings, but it was also much,
much more restrained than we see here.
It's called a flamboyant blade. Cause it looks like flames.
What these sharp wavy edges do is
constantly present a curved surface to the hand.
So it is impossible to grab it without cutting your hand open.
Even if you were wearing a leather glove,
occasionally you will find one that has got some gilding on the cross guard or
on the promo,
but you really need to leave the blade as plain as possible because you don't
want to compromise the integrity of the blade.
You don't want to chisel into it so that you couldn't put a golden light.
You don't want to scroll and actually Pierce Pearson punch or do
anything to it.
That blade needs to perform to save your life,
leave it alone.
Wearing.
A sword on your back. The Witcher three.
So here we see a really familiar trope,
which is the sword being carried on the back in a
European medieval setting. It did not happen
The type of sword.
They using him to look similar to what we would call a medieval long sword,
which it was just a sword that you use with two hands would stand about that
height.
You just can't actually get it out.
I sort that length over the shoulder sort of worn,
wanted scabbard at the hip and outside sword. Very, very, very long sword, ah,
carried over the shoulder. It's just that simple Perry's for.
So for this one, we actually pushed as much as we can to cover the,
all the parts.
Starts by getting the armor wrong by trying to give a
sense of,
of bulk and therefore presumably manners that amplifying
the size of the armor to those shoulders and making these
creatures into these great sort of automatons who move in a
very awkward and lumbering way.
This idea of wide swings and opening yourself up. And then, you know,
15 minutes later landing the blow.
It has nothing to do with reality,
the art of sword fighting it's constantly keeping yourself covered.
They weren't lumbering slow falls.
They were martial artists, athletes, lightning,
fast reflexes who had a system,
a fighting style that was immensely sophisticated.
Next let's take a look at access, throwing an ax more now.
Yeah.
What we see here is two types of acts,
a larger acts that he's using with two hands. He takes out a smaller acts,
which he uses to throw
looking at the armor and the clothing.
It looks to be more kind of late medieval. Uh,
and both of those axes shown are from a much, much,
much earlier medieval period from the sort of Frankish Saxon Viking
period. The axes of the later medieval period,
wasn't known as battle axes were predominantly a Horseman's weapon.
They're not for throwing the Polacks for honor.
They carry the most versatile weapon ever invented.
First.
Then the narrator is calling it a Polacks instead of a Polacks the worst such
things as pole arms, and a whole family of weapons that are,
that are on long poles.
But the Polacks P O double L X is what Knights
called this slightly shorter polo.
The Polacks was between four and five foot in height.
Not, not, not a super long poem. It,
it it's very much a weapon that nights when they were fighting on foot,
this was their favorite weapon. It was substantial. And at the top end,
it had an ax head and a hammerhead. You know, this was a great chunk of metal.
So that could land a fearsome bow.
On top of that was a and most importantly at the bottom
was this steel spike, a.
Secret, the peak.
And it was that air that you did most of your fighting with them.
When they arrived.
One of the great advantages of the Polacks is it has region.
You can really work at close distance and long distance.
And when you get in there, you can use that shaft as a lever.
They're doing it here. And that is right.
That is straight out of the manuals that you get that in there,
you get it behind that legs. It's the right spirit of the thing.
Let's see how bows and arrows are portrayed in video games,
the crossbow Mount. Okay.
[Inaudible].
One of the cunning things about this clip is they don't
show you how the crossbow is being lit.
I have this really rather unrealistic, right?
A shooting.
The thing called a belt and claw where a claw hung from a belt and you went down
and hooked that under the thing. And you had your foot in the then,
and you used your whole pot to strain and your legs and your thighs was
straining to pull that string back and, and hook it behind the trigger.
It certainly.
Couldn't be done as quickly as in this clip
loading and aiming chivalry.
There are two stages to preparing that Longbow to shoot.
The first one is what we call knocking. And that's the, you know,
the little notch at the end of the arrow and getting that fitted to the strip.
This clip, the speed of getting the arrow onto the strip was credible. That,
that I could shoot that fast. Maybe even a little faster.
What takes longer is the second stage.
The drawing back you're drawing a long bow from your feet to your neck.
Every muscle is engaged in pulling that string back and you
pull it back here behind the ear.
A Longboat is a powerful weapon,
180 pounds, maybe even 200 pounds draw weight.
The amount it takes to pull that string back.
This is a massive athletic
endeavor that has to be repeated over and over again.
So there are questions of stamina.
Although we don't see very much of him, we can see part of his arches equipment,
which is a leather bracelet on the inside of his left
forearm. And what it's for is it's for string slap.
As the string comes through, it just can't catch that arm. Just get us now,
have you got 150, 180 200 pound Longbow.
I can assure you that string slap. You never want to pull that bow back again.
Flaming arrows chivalry too.
So it looks great. Doesn't it? We see these incendiary arrows,
like the lightning strikes streaming across the sky.
My experience with flaming hours is they don't stay a light in the sky looking
quite so wonderful as that, but they do work and they did exist.
Does it have any practical military function?
And is it real well?
You certainly wouldn't use them in an open battlefield like that because it's
pointless. What are you going to do? Set individual people alight as a bonus,
cause you've already guilt with your error.
You would use them in sieges and in Tara raids,
fire has always been a dreadful,
awful terrible weapon.
Let's look at some other medieval weapons that are popular in video
games, Spears, Maude house
Wantage of a spear is its reach. Uh,
you got cavalry coming towards you. You can extend it. You know,
you can go for the horse. The disadvantage of a spear is its reach.
There's that much of weapon on the end of a stick.
Once you've extended and thrust that if the person gets inside that point,
it's easy to either Cleve your thin wooden shaft with,
with their sword or their ax,
or to get hold of that spear and wrench it out of your hand.
Once he's inside the point, the speed is useless. Mace chivalry.
Yeah.
Macy's is a general blunt force.
Weapon were widespread on the medieval battlefield.
What we see here when they call it a maze, it's more like a morning star,
which is a kind of a two handed mace with spikes on,
which came in a little bit later.
Something that all.
Armor had in common is it deflected below.
It gave a skidding surface.
It's very difficult to get that energy into the man underneath,
unless you can get a microsecond of bite.
So that's really what the spikes before they look really grizzly and play into
our idea of a medieval brutality.
But all that for is for grabbing hold of the target
in order to deliver the energy through the armor
flail for honor.
Their flail is as dangerous to the wielder as it is to the,
I mean, the.
Idea is if the same as a mace, it's a blunt force drama rapid,
but it's disadvantages. Having struck that Jane goes limp and comes down.
You'd have to prepare it with relatively wide strokes.
We really have no strong evidence that it was ever
a real thing. We do have evidence, however,
that it was thought of throughout the medieval period,
military engineers and artists and designers produced military
manuals.
Sometimes, however you find a diamond in the rough.
The DaVinci was one of a long line of designers of military machines.
A lot of machines and ideas in here never
happened. Daggers, dark, sorry.
The dagger uses very little stamina.
So you can attack many times over before depleting your stamina,
even if you have low internal.
So daggers were pretty much a universal weapon on the,
on the medieval battlefield.
Everybody carried a dagga clearly a weapon of last resort.
It's a weapon of close hand to hand fighting.
What I found extraordinary on this clip is whether the aeration said do note
that the range is short. I just wanted to shout on his ear. Well,
let go of one hand and you'll double your reach because obviously you've got
limited reach if you're working like that. But you know,
I've now got double league.
It's about how you use what you.
It's a one handed weapon. It's not a two handed weapon.
Now we're going to talk about tactics taking over a village kingdom,
come deliverance.
This clip had the, the element of surprise and you know,
for any attack on a village to be successful, it needs an element of surprise.
Of course, if you're attacking with an army of that size,
there's not going to be any surprise.
You would hear them from miles away.
You would see the clouds of dust from miles away.
So raiding parties would be small.
You wouldn't need more than 2030 men to raid a village like that.
They'd use incendiary arrows.
They would get up through with flaming torches and drop them in the buildings.
You don't need a big army to attack a small village.
You do need surprise firebomb weapons for honor. Did we get 12?
It's pretty excessive.
They had clay pots,
which they filled with what was really Greek fire,
which was a secret recipe developed in 70 or so by my
clinicals. And this was an incredible flammable substance that,
that just kept on burning that even burn on water.
Take that sir.
Around the battlefield with a flammable pots are pretty dangerous
business.
It's not like pulling the pin on a grenade where you know exactly the moment
you're going to throw it.
They really need to be deployed from a fixed position and best used in a range
weapon. Like first of all, with a great CG engine,
like a trevorshay circle formation, mountain blade,
[inaudible]
Certain cavalry situations or circle formation is exactly what you
need. Especially if you're outnumbered the Scott scolded,
the Shelton pioneered that.
No.
So much. I would suggest against, uh, an artillery attack with an arrow storm.
The Bowman only have to range slightly differently.
And they've got the backs of the people undefended with their
shields at that the other side of the circle
Come and get me, shoot me in the back.
I wouldn't choose a circle that size because there's so much
room in the middle.
You could get quite a lot of horsemen smashing through the line of two that
you've got there and they could wreak havoc round the backs of the other troops.
Don't periodically keep breaking your formation.
Otherwise there's no point in having it fighting on horseback
Mount and blade banner
Marie can be used in two main ways.
You have heavy cavalry smashing into a massive troops for the
impact charge.
And you have light cavalry with swords or bows or
even light lances, skirmishing or raiding,
or just hurrying troops on the battlefield.
Yeah.
Yeah. We're seeing versatile light cavalry skirmishing.
The weapon. The.
First strike for the horseman is the Lance,
the long Lance over your back.
That's the cavalry charge, but it's a one strike weapon,
one kebabs each, and you're done.
It's greatest benefit is not just the speed of delivering attacks.
It's the ability to pull back and come again,
Ability on a horse.
You couldn't even begin to match with a man on foot.
[Inaudible].
You know, the stamina of a horse to do those repeated attacks.
That's really where it gives you the edge.
Let's look at defensive weapons, shield shapes, mod,
how.
I wanted to talk about shields and Mortel okay.
The earliest type shown in this clip is the kite shield.
You can easily block pretty much anything in front of.
A sort of Norman style shield from the sort of
11th century by the 12th hundred had already gone out.
So it has a very limited time period to a very specific culture.
The kite shield is a much larger shields.
That pretty much envelops the entire body from head to your shins.
Usually that shield gets shorter and more compact
as armor for the lower leg gets better.
And you end up with what's called the heater shield.
Very good for protecting the upper torso, especially when you're on horseback.
And you need that extra layer of protection too.
With Stan,
the extraordinary force of being struck with a
Lance by a man on a horse.
Moving on to the peri shields, we have the targe and the bucket.
The Taj around shield. This one is specifically a kind of Scott's weapon.
It it's smaller than the Viking round shield. It had, you know,
more maneuverability.
Rather than just blocking with your weapon. You simply block with your shield.
The Highland Scots were famous for their charge running in that kilt across the
Heather. You don't want something clumsy. You want something light,
but they're facing arrows.
That's what shields are for they're for facing arrow storms. The better.
Clara and the targe have very minor differences between them but functioning
exactly the same in terms of size.
They have the exact same block radius.
The type of shield that is used almost exclusively for hand-to-hand fighting
is the buckler. This was a specialist, little shield, little round shield,
completely faced with steel, a little steel fist.
You use it like a fist. You punch the enemies, weapons away,
swords coming in here. You punch it away, very skillful,
but very fast flowing way of fighting.
The final shield and Morehouse is the paradise.
The [inaudible] complete polar opposite of the buckler.
The [inaudible] is a static shield.
It just sits there.
It can be placed down pretty much anywhere.
I'm a flat surface or even rough terrain.
Crossbow.
One carried on their backs set up on the battlefield because
they had to shelter behind something to work.
The claw mechanism of loading their bows.
It was a question of different shields for different fields,
but they all had a different Arma mod.
Wow.
The most important thing about armor is that it gives you as much protection as
possible.
Yeah.
The second most important thing about armor is that it allows you to fight
as well as possible.
What I love about this clip is that it starts with a Knight running
whilst wearing armor.
That is a reality a night would be able to run to
sprint in Alma Boosie code one of the generals of the French army at
Agincourt. He was known to go for a mile run in his armor every morning.
The Dropkick is probably a little bit fantastical, but, um,
I was designed for the fighting man,
the way we see a sword siting through arm, and that that's just playing fantasy.
It was fine as fantasy, but it's certainly not a reality.
So there's a lot of different types of armor playtime at the time that we're
seeing here a second skin of metal and excess skeleton of
metal,
where the night became a walking work of art and it was tailored to
precision so that every joint articulated
the most vulnerable points are those articulation points.
So if you are raising your sword to strike,
then that is more vulnerable than the bits covered with a plate,
but they had things called [inaudible], which, which are little metal discs.
They have solutions to these problems.
So there is this constant trade off between weight,
articulation and protection.
[Inaudible].
That has been extremely interesting to me as a dull old historian,
to look at how these weapons are represented in video games.
What's exciting about video games today is it's often the first hook,
the first lure to get young minds interested in history and
history is exciting and we mustn't lose the excitement just
because of a few details that might not be right.